pour les garçons les mannequins ce sont
des filles assez volages et assez
légères et ça il y a beaucoup de garçons
ne considèrent comme ça bientôt me
considérant comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Arlette le roux
71 53 kg tour d'État 58 tour de poitrine
82 tour de hanche 85 raison sociale
mannequin chez Pierre Cardin
[Musique]
Arlette vous êtes devenu Sabine depuis
combien de temps depuis un mois
exactement
j'étais dans les ateliers et
je travaillais je faisais les manteaux
et les robes
et vous avez changé pourquoi pour gagner
davantage oh non pas du tout pour mon
propre plaisir
pour vous c'est une promotion d'être
mannequin
bon je sais pas exactement je sais pas
vos parents ont-ils dit à votre avis
est-ce qu'elle va bien faire bah oui je
pense tout au moins
c'est un beau métier pour vous oui
à quel point de vue
c'est que elle pourra
je sais pas moi
pourra réussir davantage et c'est vous
qui avez décidé que Arlette ferait de la
couture
c'est-à-dire ça lui plaisait beaucoup
alors on s'est sacrifié un petit peu
pour y faire apprendre et vous Monsieur
Le Roux
que pensez-vous des mannequins
moi les mannequins
on n'est pas placé pour savoir
exactement le métier que c'est on peut
pas se rendre compte
exactement oui mais votre fille vous en
a parlé elle vous a dit ce qu'elle
allait faire
nous a peut-être pas expliqué exactement
le métier que c'était elle passe des
robes elle défie dans des robes d'un
grand couturier devant des gens qui vont
acheter ces robes en Suisse
pour moi je me rends pas compte
tandis que lorsque vous pensez qu'elle
était dans un atelier de couture vous
vous rendiez mieux compte
pourquoi pensez-vous qu'elle a changé
qu'elle a préféré être mannequin
elle a préféré être mannequin parce que
elle aspect a gagné plus d'argent
ce qui est une raison ça doit être la
seule raison je pense que pensez-vous
des mannequins vous
je sais pas on dit que tous les
mannequins sont des chipies oh non je
pense qu'on a pas été méchante avec elle
on a accueilli très bien et elle est-ce
que vous sentez vraiment qu'elle est en
train de venir mannequin vraiment oh oui
je pense que le train
il y a quand même une adaptation
je crois qu'elle lui plaisait il aimait
sa façon de marcher d'évoluer dans le
salon
et il a transformé il a beaucoup changé
lui a fait couper les cheveux elle avait
les cheveux longs et maintenant les
cheveux très courts bouclés ça lui va
très bien et il lui a fait changer de
maquillage vous l'auriez rencontrer vous
dans la rue vous auriez eu l'idée d'en
faire un mannequin
[Musique]
peut-être mais
je sais pas en fait quand même un petit
peu raide encore dans sa façon de
marcher et puis je sais pas je crois
qu'elle a besoin beaucoup de se
décontracter parce que
nous on l'a très bien accueilli
mais elle est peut-être encore un peu
contractée avec nous et
il y a des choses qu'on n'ose pas lui
dire enfin André rivet quel est le
personnage le plus important dans une
maison de couture une bonne ouvrière ou
un bon mannequin
parce que c'est une robe bien faite
elle peut être très laide sur mannequin
une robe très mal faite peut être très
bien enlevé par mannequin
Michel pensez-vous carlette et bien fait
de venir mannequin oui très bien
pourquoi
le désirait depuis longtemps elle vous
en parlait oui
[Musique]
il est très ami avec Arlette oui c'est
vous qui l'avez décidé aussi
vous trouvez que c'est plus agréable
d'être mannequin c'est travailler dans
un atelier pourquoi
c'est pas du tout la même chose une
simple
vous accepteriez pourquoi
d'abord
le moment le plus fatigant malgré tout
c'est vraiment des pauses c'est à dire
au moment de la collection au moment où
Monsieur Cardin crée ses modèles et
c'était vraiment à ce moment là le plus
dur
c'est un métier où on gagne beaucoup
moins d'argent il faut quand même le
dire
y a-t-il des avantages
5000 francs cinq dix mille francs par
photo
il y a les croquis
et on a l'avantage d'avoir une robe ou
intérieure quand on a l'intention de
sortie le coiffeur enfin et est-ce que
vos amis ont changé avec vous depuis que
vous avez vous-même changé le métier non
mes amis n'ont pas du tout changé
vous la voyez pratiquement plus gros
parfois
je trouvais qu'elle a changé
à quel point de vue
avec nous je trouve des garçons Sabine
est-ce que ça se passe la même façon ah
non pas du tout c'est à dire
vraiment le mauvais côté de la chose
étant donné mannequin pour eux les pour
les garçons les mannequins ce sont des
filles assez volages et assez légères et
ça bien beaucoup de garçons ne
considèrent comme ça bientôt me
considérant comme ça
pourtant ce n'est pas du tout mon cas
oui à l'atelier j'étais obligé de
recommencer mais en tant que mannequin
vous recommencez aussi oui on commence
mais c'est pas un travail manuel je
pense pas vraiment quelque chose de
précis je regarde les clientes mais je
ne les vois pas je peux pas dire
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai vu une cliente avec
des lunettes ou des cheveux roux ça je
peux pas dire on va la rentrer chez moi
me vouloir trouver la petite vie
habituelle que je retrouvais chaque soir
quand je rentrais en ordinaire quand je
rentrais de l'atelier
alors là c'est le moment de repos
vous avez abandonné une profession que
vous connaissiez bien pour un métier
capricieux que vous connaissez peu oui
et que vous allez exercer 10 ans tout de
plus oh non certainement même pas 10 ans
non je pense pas l'exercice 10 ans
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire ce que
mon désir moi serait d'avoir une petite
maison de couture enfin ça c'est pas
encore
j'espère quand même un retour réussir
dans ce milieu là aussi
vous faites 5 km par jour
devant des clients qui ne vous voient
ça c'est sûr et qu'il voit que les robes
oui c'est dur
oui oui quand même c'est assez dur
si vous aviez une fille voudriez-vous
qu'elle soit mannequin oh oui parce que
on a davantage l'occasion de sortir de
rencontrer beaucoup de personnes et ça
c'est une chose indispensable pour une
fille je trouve connaître du monde
oui je crois
je trouve que pour une femme c'est
vraiment un beau métier
[Musique]